so in this session we are very talks
they are a little shorter than the
previous talker so they will be in 20
factoring those questions the first one
is I'd like to comment on it right thank
you very much mark
can you hear me okay yes it's thanks
very much for this opportunity to come
to the workshop and to to give a talk
here it's actually not the first time in
California I spent five years here doing
my PhD down at Caltech in Pasadena which
I did in physics I don't I'm coming here
without a background in most of the
topics that you you mostly have and
these days actually I'm not in research
I'm in software development so I won't
be presenting on on research so
from me but what I want to do is talk to
you about a tool that we're building
with the Australian or in collaboration
with the Australian Bureau of Statistics
for confidential eyes contingency tables
and really I'm hoping to learn from you
guys about you know how we can do this
in such a way as to make you know a
broader access in a safe way
so I might just start by saying you know
where I work and giving you a little bit
of context so I'm not with the ABS the
Australian gross digit um I'm actually
with the CSIRO which is stands for the
Commonwealth Scientific Industrial
Research Organisation and that is an
applied research agency I'm not sure
there's quite an equivalent in the US
it's been around for about a hundred
years and it was focused on creating
economic environmental and social
benefits for Australia and for the world
there's lots of research is in there
there's some statistics I mean a data
science part of that and it's called
data 61 nothing to do with area 51 if
you're worried it's the 61 is actually
about
that's just an oblique reference to
Australia and and data sixty ones
mission is to solve Australia's
data-driven challenges and so some
examples of things that have happened
recently that we've just spun out an
institute called the gradient Institute
looking at ethically aware machine
learning
there's a trustworthy Systems Group
which is working on provably correct
software and in particular a Linux
microkernel called self or there's
blockchain group and a confidential
computing group as well working on
secure multi-party
so how did I get them involved in
working with the ABS I think it dates
back to public data policy statement
made by the Australian Government in
December of 2015 which I've just pulled
out two lines from that which are
basically to try and make the government
agencies should make non sensitive data
open by default so that sort of got us
thinking you know this is a data driven
challenge to first rally to do this in a
safe way
right and so you know we got involved in
the first thing we did was we ran some
workshops with government agencies and
tried to understand what the barriers to
making go over and you know we came up
with is it's a key one of course
including cost and data quality
so we have a little schematic that sort
of tries to organize some of the ways
we're helping government address some of
those issues so across the top there we
have kind of a journey that one possible
journey anyway for data that coming out
from a from a government to outcomes and
we have a number of things that we're
doing a few of these to try and help
governments so underuse starting at the
end here there's a mapping project
called national map and that's that is
like great way so the H government
agency doesn't have to create their own
way of that can access data anywhere in
the world in fact but you know we've
designed it for Australia and just show
you that on the map one particular thing
that's been used for recently is drought
map which has been helping to
understand what the impact of the
drought in Australia so there's access
to satellite data and so forth then
under access this federated registry in
search that refers to a replacement for
the you have data.gov in America we have
gotten a you and how that works so you
make it easier to discover data we're
talking about open data then all I am
since coming here thinking that some of
the talks
for example the site or in one of the
early days maybe there's a way that we
could because this is federated and you
don't actually have to put the data
there you can just put a reference to
the data
some put some information some metadata
about okay so so that's interesting and
then okay so now coming back to protect
which is more where I'm coming in two
things that I'll mention here so
synthetic data generation we do have a
privacy research team that's affiliated
with us and Macquarie University in
Sydney that has been working on
synthetic data generation so they've in
the last few years released a synthetic
data set for some of the tap on tap off
transport data in Sydney for example and
they also are working on helping
government agencies okay it synthetic
data sets out of there well
unfortunately a stack with me not
someone from who knows the details of
that research in in this workshop so I
can't really
but we are talking to them very very
much about what I'm doing which is the
confidential
so um right it's not just company
confidential eyes contingency tables of
course it's custom ones I don't know why
I made it such a probably should have it
easier to say but yeah basically what
this means is that a user can come to
our website you know the ABS is website
and generate a custom and table of
counts if they're authorized on the data
set that they have authorization to
access and that means you know they can
choose some hypercube and so yeah the
the sorts of protections that you would
be totally familiar with other than
perturbation and we're using the
algorithm that whose salient features I
guess Natalie has already described to
you I guess some key aspects to that are
that each each individual in the
microdata gets a record key and the
perturbation that's applied to each cell
depends on who's in there so it's it's
deterministic
fashion table that you look up and say
yeah one other key aspect of that that
would need to be changed at a minimum
would be that the zeros are so selves
that are zeroed cannot be changed away
certainly selves that are not zero it
could become there
like a aggregation of course so that you
know you can't ask arbitrary sequel
queries about the data you can only ask
for counts means or sums as well so
that's that's a whole and and then the
other key thing about this which I guess
is heading a little bit you know you
know sort of a way towards what
differential privacy you would want with
a risk budget is that it does limit how
many queries each user can ask okay so
so in fact the ABS has a tool already
that we've been talking about that does
a lot of these things already the the
reason we're involved I guess is because
we want to try and make government data
available more generally for other
agencies as well and maybe for other
datasets within the ABS so so so you
know that's what that's our goal and so
we're doing it as an API which is not
it's a quick sidetrack to the API isn't
is so I guess an API you mostly be aware
which is just a layer between the data
and the software that you're using so a
user doesn't typically want to interact
with the power of an API of course is
that you can have multiple different
pieces of software so we have built a
prototype user interface which I'll give
you a quick demo I found a couple of
things I'll draw your attention to here
one is that its name with meconium Atari
which is protection against for
identification the second is that it
does actually access the unit record
data that's with for PII removed and so
does the perturbation on the fly
okay and where are we at at the moment
so the ABS is trialing this on a small
group of authorized users at the moment
on one of their data sets its data set
called the matter basic longitudinal
extract so that's our value data set its
met up stands for multi-agency data
integration project so it is linked
across a number of agencies it sounds a
little bit like what Christine talked
about not sorry Gillian talked about
yeah and of course the point of all this
is of course to you know in answer
policy questions and be able to inform
policy but there are lots of fields in
this you know about a hundred fields so
it's an interesting challenge it's there
and you know if you don't the only other
way to access this data set at the
moment is through a secure arm
so what do I want to do in the rest of
the talk here I just want to give you a
quick demo and then you know talk a
little bit about why I'm here and what
I'm hoping to learn and ideas that I've
got how this might work let me just jump
over to so just a quick two-minute demo
I guess being a software developer oh I
want to so first of all you have to sign
in so we're using Open ID Connect as a
way to vacation it shows you the terms
and conditions that you would have
already had to agree to those to get
authorization in the first place and you
of them you can choose what data set
you're talking about here this is all
dummy data that I'm showing here you can
choose what columns of the data that
you're interested in a filter was up
there saying I mean
and you can download the the results so
have a look at I wanted to just give a
quick example of one of the nice things
you can do with the results they can
come out in a geographical format SPG au
au and national map knows how to
understand that so you know those are
all places in Australia you can download
it in that format and then drag it onto
national map and it will show you the
same data on a map rather than in a
table
this outside the Wi-Fi was a little bit
slower than just dragging that same
thing we just downloaded and it so
nationalmap understands the names of all
these code it's a nice synergy I guess
between the different things
and you can say the the other dimension
that you downloaded is showing over on
the left see all these numbers have
perturbed of course
I think that's one tiny last thing on
the demo is then just this is counts you
can also do means and sums
non categorical fields and I think in
Madoff actually there are none there are
no such fields like that so it's
actually just counts at the moment
so the the bigger matter data said also
involves other tables so this is this is
one advantage of this I guess at the
moment in terms of a differential
privacy way of thinking about it is that
it is just one table but later of course
most real data is typically not one
table so we're also looking at ways to
try and extend this to join tails
okay so
okay so that's the demo so why am I here
that's that's all that so I guess you
know maybe a bit naively now that I've
been here for a little while I've been
wondering yeah can we use differential
privacy to safely increase access to
this sort of thing and I can see I think
from talking to people and I might need
to add another one to hereafter talk
after hearing but the sort of the sort
of options that I see that we use
synthetic data or noisy hyper tables
that have a finite responder the use
along the lines that people have talked
about I think that would be a great
solution if we can do it obviously I
think with a hundred fields that's
trying to find some piece that's still
useful that can do that I think
maybe one that I suspect I'll get a bit
of flack for suggesting here but it
might be an approach is to is sort of
along the lines we've got right now
where you've you've got a each user has
a limit of how many queries they can ask
but then there's more than one user and
that's where you cap its users risk
budget maybe at some point you have to
cut that off yeah and maybe maybe as a
variant on that you you could possibly
different risk budgets
and then yeah and then I guess part of
part of maybe part of that might be that
my thinking there is that the global
responded is is designed with that
worst-case idea in mind and maybe
that's just and then the final one which
certainly worth put on the table I think
is is this actually what we should be
doing in the different lot of people
actually using this for and should we be
helping them do that so you know to that
end we have actually interviewed a
number of our users in that in that
trial set of 15 or so people and they
were written by and large trying to help
answer policy questions and they said to
us that the contingency tables were
helping them do that so I think after
this workshop I'd I might go back to
them and talk to them more and try and
understand how they were really doing
that and whether that is really that
okay yeah I guess the other question is
you know with one and two even with one
and two you're gonna have to use some
responder to generate those tables
really what you're trying to do is
something
I look up hesitating whether I should
put this slide up but I we have been
coming in here I sort of felt the
question was all around what algorithm
do you pick and so it's been great of
the puzzle so we you know we looked at
just using the adult data set that's
actually in published in whim paper what
if you do so this is this is actually
the published line this frame line but
I've taken the square root so you can
better self and the sort of queries that
are involved in this study are range
queries so you know give me the number
of people who are between two certain
ages and to certain hours worked and I
was a little bit horrified when I first
looked at this and said well that's
adding that out you know sort of
typically a noise of a thousand to every
answer which is much higher than users
would expect
then I realize the reason why that's
that's happening with the +2 right and I
realized later the reason that that's
happening is because of course you're
adding that noise to each individual
cell and so when here you know that's
just gonna happen right so so in that
sense at first I thought wow he moves
really not that much better than last
but actually that could really mean
something right because
I should point out the be the data sets
32,000 rows and actually often I've
noticed in papers they always say it's
48,000 rows and that's as far as I can
tell just because the metadata says it's
48,000
yeah so you know on top of that there's
a there's a gal the challenges that I we
face and in particular you know things
like weights and longitudinal data and
categorical fields and join tables and
means and sums they're all they sound
like most of those are still open
questions and and in particular I would
love to be able to put a confidence
interval and edge count so if we have if
we do use an algorithm other than the
place on
I noticed even in Michaels talk you said
that was a research to say yeah so I
guess I hope you don't mind that I
haven't presented anything particularly
a shattering on differential privacy but
I've really enjoyed the opportunity to
show you what I'm doing and use that as
an opportunity to find out from you guys
where I should be focusing for your you
mentioned that current the they get play
totally authorized users that are able
to make use of your exist exist because
they a bit about who these authorized
users are and um so it's it's it's
within other government agencies across
the federal government and authorized
like new and and other researchers from
universities who that's what the IPS has
to approve that they
I had the same question
and they have transition process I think
it's really a matter of signing that
you're not going to try and
our list question can they can then
publish tablespace stop I was expecting
this question yes that's right following
ones argument if there were enough of
them published it might be able to
reconstruct well that's why at the
moment it's a limited trial and and
there's limited risk budget no sorry
limited number of queries I get asked
but do they have presumably they have to
move in to come and work in a safe haven
or through a VPN or something
well no so this is this is something I
can access through the web actually
the you know your idea of kind of
private versus public use and you know
whether or private versus published if
you seem an interesting one presumably
for any of this there is some externally
visible impact of the work at some point
otherwise yes yes I realize you know but
it does lead to an interesting question
of could you base the privacy budget
somehow on what they actually do with
the data rather than what they've
actually seen it feels to me like the
impact of publishing that data is
greater than the impact of using it to
guard the next page of analysis but I
well you said you talked to the some
about what they're doing hers and how
far do you carry that do you carry that
the point where you say what's actually
going to happen that someone could
externally view
I think that would be an interesting
thing to learn is it yeah we're going to
make the following policy we're going to
make the following dollar allocation
assumably check the disclosure well the
point of this is that it's it's done for
you at the perturbation when people work
on that database they're going to send
it to a journal or write it now what you
have to check it before doing well
that's true of the secure data Enclave
but not true of a tool like this as far
as the point right is the perturbation
is not a bit of disclosure limitation so
it's sort of interesting model that you
might actually let somebody query a
collection of government data for
private use without requiring that it be
query be put in the public domain and we
can't do that but Australia may be
allowed to do that essentially for
bosons
you created I haven't checked the
legality of that but what was an idea
yes I
what about differential privacy makes
you interested in the opposite or the
formal framework
well I guess you know our mandate I
guess is to make more data accessible
safely so it's really just making sure
and safe and I guess yeah the fact that
it's a formal guarantee I really like it
myself
and
fact that it could lead to it's not just
a matter of clamping down on what it's
also a matter of being able to
if I hurry great he said something about
that you feel like you have to you can't
multiply the 0 so 0 is just a 0 that
well that's the way it works now is that
coming is there some policy reason for
that or no I think it's probably just a
sense that that's what the users would
it would disrupt the users too much to
do I would I would certainly want to
challenge that it's from very poorly
worked out there are model of the users
[Music]
so that I guess is on the algorithm then
for example there are other protections
like being authorized and would you
freak so there but there has been some
attack about some IPS metals for
releasing private data you can just
Google ideas
we step up this table maker over 100
music it wasn't on a live system it was
on a simulated is the wasn't sure this
table maker was the Siri on the to
simulate what it's if I simulated the
algorithm so it's so but but the one you
have here you mention it has restricted
access and so given the access rules and
the number of query rules could let it
happen
[Music]
it depends on what the limits are that
are in there and not sure what the abs
actually said those limits at so I guess
there's different levels of confidence
as well so the more you know if you
could do a million queries obviously
thanks everybody
[Applause]